hi oh don't pee on me hello
Oh puppies hey I'm Demi lavato and I'm
hanging out with some puppies while
answering your questions how am I
supposed to start answering questions oh
hello you're a boy I just found that out
I like the brown ones they're playful
can you describe your new album tell me
you love me in three words nope
my album in three words would be
vulnerable raw and soulful here we go
nope would you release the song in
Spanish in the future if so which latin
artist would you like to collaborate
with I actually oh those are my pants no
no honey you will have to wait and find
out because I recorded something
recently and that I think you will like
oh my God why did you decide to name
your album tell me you love me I decided
to name my album tell me you love me
because it's one of my favorite songs
off of the album and it also is a very
vulnerable and raw title
oh no we peed on his face bones boom no
how is this album different than
confident or any of your other albums
this album is different than my other
albums because it's more soulful and I
think it's the most mature out of all
the albums that I've made and I've done
a lot of growing up personally and
professionally so I think that that's
the reason why you can help me read the
question I recently just got out of a
long-term relationship I was wondering
how you deal with a breakup I deal with
a breakup by leaning on my closest
friends and by getting out into the
dating scene again I think that it's
important not to do
on certain things and just to get back
out there and have fun oh my god this
these are my pants and that's my finger
and that's my next question are you
planning on directing are you planning
on directing more of your music videos
like how you directed made-in-the-usa I
love to direct at some point but maybe
the next one who knows you've had such
an amazing career so far what has been
your best achievement I think having a
number-one single was definitely a
career highlight and also getting my
grandma nomination what's your favorite
tattoo that you have and are you
planning on getting more I'm not
planning on getting more as of right now
but that'll change I'm sure my favorite
tattoo is my lion on the hand you're an
inspiration to your fans and to other
people who have gone through tough times
what does it mean to you to be able to
inspire and change the lives of others
through your fame I think that it's
really important that you use your
platform for good and if I've been able
to use my tough times and use them as
theirs puppies I don't know there's
puppies I think that if I'm able to use
the difficult times that I've been
through as lessons for other people then
I think I'm happy to inspire others nope
those are my questions
what song on your newest album do you
think is the most personal I think the
most personal song on this album
is either you don't do it for me anymore
or ready for you
I think ready for you is a song that I
wrote that explains a lot about a
breakup that I went through after
watching your cover of Silent Night I
couldn't help but think would you ever
consider making a Christmas album I have
considered making a Christmas album
hopefully I'll do that soon you never
know social media can be really tough on
a person mentally any tips on staying
sane and confident in a world where
every photo is face tuned and
photoshopped well I think that learning
to love yourself is very important and
learning to love yourself in the skin
that you're in is very important it can
be difficult at times that of course the
pressures are high but I think that as
long as you love yourself that's all
that matters
what's the most funniest the most
funniest memorable prank you've ever
pulled and who did you pull it on the
funniest prank that I ever pulled on
somebody was I pulled a prank on my
security guard and in Vegas it's legal
to hire a lady of the night to make
surprise visits for somebody so I did
that and I sent her to my security
guards room and told her to be very
forceful and make herself enter the room
and she did just that and he was very
startled and I am glad that he didn't
keep her which song in this record was
the hardest to write / record the
hardest song to record was smoke and
mirrors which is on the deluxe version
of the album it was a very emotional
song that I wrote on that basically
reminded me what are you doing venting
that's my elbow what are you doing that
reminded me of some very emotional times
that I went through do you want to act
again I think I would love to act at
some point I've just been so focused
with music right now that I haven't had
the chance to
what has been your favorite fan
interaction or experience I haven't had
a favorite fan experience because all of
them are so special I think that anytime
a fan tells me that I've saved their
life is extremely meaningful and it just
matters so much to me and it's kind of
unfathomable so it really means a lot
last question who's the first person you
call when you have good news the first
person I call is either my mom or my
best friend Marissa it's definitely my
mom actually and then I call Marissa but
I tell them good news and I get so
excited for me because they're so
supportive and I love them so much
interviewing with puppies was so much
fun they are so adorable I wish I could
take all of them home but you actually
can they are from North Shore Animal
League America and they're all up for
adoption so hashtag get your rescue on
so that's all I have I'm gonna go play
with puppies now because they're so
adorable
and they're very very playful right now
oh sweet